estamos en compañía del ex balance
valentino valentine valentayn valentín
que es miembro del dúo lola con doble a
al final es un dúo de toronto cómo estás
lex muy bien cómo están todos muy bien
muchas gracias gracias por aceptar la
entrevista para radio canadá
internacional
lex tú y tu hermana crearon este dúo
hace dos años
y ahora han tenido mucho éxito nos están
conociendo cada vez más particularmente
en toronto
pero se está extendiendo un poco más por
el resto de canadá también cómo se
sienten ustedes cómo surgió este este
proyecto porque ustedes hacen música
hace mucho tiempo sí bueno te estaba
diciendo antes mi hermana empezamos con
otro proyecto a los 16 años que se
llamaba magnet alaine éramos bien
chavitas en ese entonces pero ese
proyecto duró 10 años y ya después de
eso bueno ya mi no creces como persona y
cambian las cosas y decidimos que
queremos hacer otro proyecto entonces
este proyecto se llama lola y bueno
cuando nosotros vamos creciendo
escuchamos
son música mucha música así como daniela
romo gloria trevi lo que es la música el
estilo pop no y ya como después ya
cuando terminó este proyecto nos fuimos
al estudio y empezamos a escribir más
música y de eso salió el hola y si no
nos sentimos muy orgullosas y allí
también poder sacar discos en español
porque eso es algo que siempre queríamos
hacer si justamente estaba leyendo por
ahí que como decías daniela romo gloria
estefan gloria trevi forman parte de
parte de sus inspiraciones porque dirías
tú que es que fue lo que más las inspiró
digamos para este para este proyecto
lola no sé creo que siempre es no sea
algo que siempre lleva vamos así como en
el corazón es parte de ser mexicana y
también parte de crecimos en una casa
muy mexicana mi mamá ella siempre tocar
a esa música los sábados cuando se ponía
a limpiar la casa no
y si binner para limpiar la casa y
también también vicente fernández pero
pero pero no así de eso es parte de
quién somos y es parte de nuestra
familia entonces se sintió una cosa
natural no para escribir música de bueno
inspirada por eso de esas personas yo
decía que estaban lanzando el proyecto y
que desde hace dos años había sido cada
vez más ha tenido como más más este
ha sido más conocido más aceptado pero
como lo ven ustedes la aceptación de
este tipo de música en español además en
una región como toronto que es
completamente o prácticamente anglófona
sin sí bueno es bueno si vice por
ejemplo no son ni audífonos o han
soportado mucho pero es difícil porque
no hay mucha música aquí en español
si no hay música así en el estilo así
como reggaeton o salsa lo que sea pero
así como música indie pop mexicana no
hay en la ciudad de méxico si hay muchos
también en monterrey bueno en méxico
y en un futuro si queremos ir a traer la
música allá
pero aquí como que yo siempre digo que
es como buscar unicornios cuando cuando
cuando encuentras a otras personas que
tocan la misma música que tú pero no es
muy común aunque el año pasado en el
2017 aunque no seamos sigue exactamente
igual
el premio polaris que es el premio más
importante de música canadiense fue
entregado al lido pimienta al clan y
además vemos el éxito que está teniendo
jessy reyes por ejemplo entonces digamos
que si hay como un interés por lo latino
pero no sé si es exactamente el mismo
tipo de música pero por lo menos interés
por latino en canadá si se es y espero
que eso continúa no claro que sí ahora
qué relación mantienen ustedes con sus
orígenes mexicanos porque usted me decía
qué bueno que escuchan muchas escuchaban
cuando crecieron música latinoamericana
en casa música latina mexicana pero qué
relación mantienen ustedes dos como como
hermanas y como grupo
méxico con américa latina' viviendo aquí
en canadá
si sabes que todavía no le he contado a
mucha gente pero ahorita estoy estoy en
proceso de aplicar por mi ciudadanía
mexicana me quiero ir a vivir allá como
en un año y siempre ha sido un sueño
para mí pero siempre regresamos allá con
la familia
una vez al año a cabo fui ahí hace unos
meses también pero siempre me ha
encantado la cultura y la gente siempre
me ha sentido así como muy orgullosa de
ser parte de ahí pero también no sé las
costumbres no todo es de familia todos
de corazón y así somos nosotras también
sí no
pero sí espero que todo salga bien
porque me quiero ir para allá
bueno cáncer en sí y qué quiere qué
quieres hacer en méxico para qué vas
bueno bueno quiero ir a tocar música
pero también quiero ir a trabajar y ahí
es donde quiero tener una familia y todo
eso no siempre he tenido ilusiones de
hacer eso undiano y tu hermana siente lo
mismo tu hermana se quedaría y bueno ya
se va a quedar aquí porque tiene un
novio por aquí no pero pero yo yo no
tengo nada que me ate aquí entonces es
siempre bueno sería un sueño y tus papás
no están aquí si ellos sí están aquí
pero ellos también se van conmigo porque
mi mamá ella ella se vino aquí como los
27 años con él se casó con mi papá mi
papá él se vino aquí a los 10 años
porque antes de bueno es una larga
historia pero mi abuelo era el embajador
de méxico en cuba en los años 60 en los
60s y después de eso ellos se fueron de
allá y se dieron acá y el vídeo no tagua
desde los 10 años y después cuando con
el tsja mi mamá se la trajo para acá
ya lleva mucho tiempo me moda siempre
dice que ella siempre quería regresar
para allá a estar con su familia y ya
lleva muchos años entonces te irías con
ellos te lo llevarías contigo sí claro
cuéntanos rápidamente para terminar lex
cuáles son los proyectos para lola y de
pasito un poco una referencia al nombre
por qué lo eligieron pero bueno un poco
los proyectos para lo line y el nombre
también sí bueno a ver que tenemos
planeado este año bueno nos vamos a
italia en diciembre
porque ya se halla en españa y en italia
siempre les encanta la música latina
entonces eso lo tenemos en los planes
también quiero ir queremos ir a tocar
más en méxico y latinoamérica
entonces vamos a ver si eso pasa en los
próximos meses pero eso lo estamos
planeando y vamos a regresar al estudio
a escribir más música ya llevamos unas
unas canciones por ahí pero nos va a
tomar unos seis siete meses y ojalá el
próximo año tengamos otro disco
en el manuel otra vez se exige en
español
primero en español esta vez porque eso
queremos condicionar este proyecto en
españa el primero que en inglés porque
el principio ustedes no va sé qué decir
a la gente que no esté escuchando que el
primero comenzaron con el inglés pero
compusieron música en inglés se
presentaron en la escena musical de
toronto en inglés y ahora en español sí
sí porque eso era la cosa más natural
que hacer porque aquí es bueno todos
hablan en inglés no pero para nosotros
siempre queríamos escribir el disco en
español
y así no bueno lo bueno viene del nombre
de dolores que era el nombre de una de
nuestras abuelas también de unas de mis
días pero siempre nos ha gustado el
significado que es bueno alegría sordos
y no sé bueno si si escuchas la letra de
la música
eso se escribió como algún tiempo donde
pasaron muchas cosas tristes en mi vida
entonces quería un nombre proyecto que
reflexionará eso pero que también se
sintiera que te diera esperanza al final
de todo de lo que había pasado no
entonces el nombre lola no sé si sintió
como la cosa más natural pero le pusimos
la segunda porque había muchos proyectos
que tenían el nombre lola entonces nada
más digno que le vamos a poner la otra y
ya ya estamos
por eso es lola con gozas y demás
decirle a la gente que no habla inglés
que lady of sorrow sería como la señora
de las dolencias o de las dolencias y si
no se sigue las tristezas
pero no son tristes ustedes o si no no
no bueno es la letra de la letra a veces
puede ser un poco triste pero siempre le
ponemos un ritmo así como que más más
feliz más feliz como daniela romo
álex valenta en muchas gracias saludos a
nadie a valeri quien tu hermana en este
proyecto lo la con doble a
gracias muchas gracias a ustedes hasta
luego entonces